i let everybody on twitter post a
thousand or ten thousand satoshi's via a
lightning wallet
a lightning badge give me an orange
check
if you put up 20 bucks once in your life
you could give 300 million people an
orange check
right now
you don't have a blue check lex you're a
famous person i don't know why you don't
have a blue check have you have you ever
applied for a blue check no there are
360 000 people on twitter with a blue
check there are 300 million people on
twitter
so the conventional way to verify uh
accounts
is elitist
archaic yeah how does it how does it
work how do you get blue check i mean
you got to apply and wait six months and
you have to post you know like three
articles in the public mainstream media
that illustrates you're a person of
interest
interesting generally they would grant
them to ceos of public companies or the
whole idea is to verify that you know
that you are
who you are who you say you are right
but the question is why isn't everybody
verified right and there's there's a
couple of threads on that one is some
people don't want to be doxxed they want
to be anonymous
but uh but there are even anonymous
people that should be verified right um
because otherwise uh you're you're
subjecting their entire following to
phishing attacks and scams and and
hostility
uh but the other
the other what's the orange verification
so the the this idea can you actually
elaborate a little bit more if you put
up 20 bucks yeah i think everybody on
twitter ought to be able to get an
orange check if they could come up with
like ten dollars and what is the power
of that orange check what what does that
verify exactly
you basically post a security deposit
for your safe passage through cyberspace
so the way it would work is if you if
you've got ten dollars once in your life
yeah you can basically show that you're
credit worthy
and that's your pledge to me
that you're going to act responsibly
so you put the 10 or the 20 into the
lightning wallet you get an orange check
then twitter just gives you a setting
where i can say the only people that
could dm me are orange checks the only
people that can post on my tweets or
orange checks
so instead of locking out the public and
just letting your followers
you know comment you lock out all the
unverified and that means people that
don't want to post 10 security deposit
can't comment once you've done those two
things
then uh you're in position to monetize
malice
right monetize motion or malice for that
matter but let's just say for the sake
of argument you post something and 9 700
bots
spin up you know and pitch their
whatever scam
right now you sit and you go
report report report report report
report and if you spend an hour you get
through half of them you waste an hour
of your life
they just spent up another 97 gazillion
because they've got a python script
spending it up so it's hopeless
but on the other hand if you report them
and they really are a bot it's
twitter's got a method to actually
delete the account they know that their
bots the problem is not they don't know
how to delete the account the problem is
there are no consequences when they
delete the account
so
if there are consequences twitter could
give they could just seize the ten
dollars or seize the twenty dollars
because it's a bot it's a it's a
malicious criminal act or whatever it
buy as a violation of platform rules
you end up seizing ten thousand dollars
give half the money to the reporter and
half the money to the twitter platform
and it's a really powerful idea but that
that's tying it that's adding friction
akin to the kind of friction you have
in the physical world you're tying you
have consequences you have real
consequences putting concert
conservation of energy conservation of
energy there's no friction there's no
nothing on this earth
right i mean you can't walk across the
room without friction
right so the friction is not bad
right uh
unnecessary friction
is bad
so in this particular case you're
introducing conservation of energy and
in essence you're introducing the
concept of consequence or truth
into cyberspace
and that means if you do want to spin up
10 million fakes fake less freedmen's
rights it's going to cost you 100
million dollars to spin up 10 million
fake lexus the thing is you could do
that with the dollar but your case
you're saying that
it's
more
tied to physical reality when you do
that with bitcoin
yeah well let's follow up on that idea a
bit more
if you did do it with the dollar
then the question is how do six billion
people deposit the dollars
right because what you're doing is yeah
could you do it with a credit card like
how do you send dollars or you have to
dox yourself
like
it's not easy so you're talking about
inputting a credit card transaction
doxing yourself and now you've just
eliminated the two billion people that
don't have credit cards or don't have
banks you've also got a problem with
everybody that wants to remain anonymous
but you've also got this other problem
which is
credit you know credit cards are
expensive transactions low frequency
slow settlement
so do you really want to pay two and a
half percent every time you actually
show a 20 deposit and maybe you could do
a kludgy version of this for a subset of
people
it's like it's ten percent as good if
you did it with uh conventional payment
rails but
what you can't do
is uh the next idea which is
i want the orange badge uh to be used to
give me safe passage through cyberspace
tripping across every platform
so when i
how do i solve the denial of service
attacks against a website i publish a
website
you hit it with a million requests
okay now how do i deal with that well i
can lock you out and i can make it a
zero trust website and then you have to
be coming at me through a trusted
firewall with a trusted credential but
that's
that's a pretty draconian thing or
i could put it behind a lightning wall
a lightning wall would be
you know i just challenge you lex uh you
wanna um browse my website you have to
show me your 100 000 satoshi's do you
have a hundred thousand satoshi's
click
okay now you click away a hundred times
or a thousand times and after a thousand
times you know i'm like well now lex
you're getting offensive over to take a
satoshi from you or 10 satoshi's a micro
transaction you want to hit me a million
times i'm taking all your satoshis and
locking you out
what what you want to do is you want to
go through 200 websites a day
and what you want every time you cross
a domain
you need to be able to in a split second
prove that you've got some asset and now
when you cross back when you exit domain
you want to fetch your asset back
so how do i in a friction-free fashion
browse through dozens or hundreds of
websites
post a security deposit for state safe
passage and then get it back
you couldn't afford to pay a credit card
fee each time
it's when you think about two and a half
percent as a transaction fee
it means you trade the money
40 times
and it's gone
yeah it's gone yeah yeah so you can't do
this kind of hopping around through the
internet with this kind of uh
verification that grounds you to a
physical reality it's it's a really
really interesting idea why haven't
hasn't that been done
i i think you need uh two things you
need an idea like a digital asset like
bitcoin that's a bearer instrument for
final settlement and then you need a
high-speed transaction network like
lightning where the transaction cost
might be a 20th of a penny
or or less
and if you roll the clock back 24 months
i don't think you had uh the lightning
network in a stable point it's really
just the past 12 months it's an idea you
could think about this year
and i think you need to you need to
be aware of bitcoin as something other
than like a scary speculative asset
you